daang tried to beat the best beat the
thirst if you look at entrepreneurship
there's a lot of different ways to win
you just have to try different things
and even even if 99% of them fail you
only have to be right one time rise and
shine it's in spresso time what's up
believe nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world so let's start
your day off right grab your coffee and
sip on today's message be the first over
to you Jack Ma dong tried to beat the
best be the first be the first to change
be the first to chat take the challenge
be the first one to overcome the
difficulties because the best person
there's only one Olympic champion I
don't think I'm lucky enough to be bad
but I can always try the new things and
don't give I believe it because you you
are so unique everybody's unique be
yourself is always the key so I think
for this is really highly dependent on
on your personality and what you like I
think there are some people who wind up
being the first and I think some people
win by being the best and I would say to
Jack's point right at the end he says be
unique be yourself that's how you could
be the best he's using the example of an
Olympic sport and yes there's only one
Olympic champion in a set to find rules
of Olympics but if you look at
entrepreneurship there's a lot of
different ways to win if you are trying
to play somebody else's game sure
there's only one Evan Carmichael there's
only one Gary Vaynerchuk there's only
one Jack Ma but there's a lot of
different ways to win and you win by
being yourself you can always be the
best yourself I make these top ten rules
of success I make these xpresso series I
love studying famous wins and failures
and learning from those experiences to
help me make
myself better I learned that to try to
share it with you guys as well and I'm
so fortunate that you love the content
and you support me and your learning
through my journey as well I love that
other people have tried to copy what I
do and they use the same top ten rules
and they put their own voice on it and
put different names on the clips and
people tell me about it I don't care
because if you are only trying to copy
me you can it be a junior version of me
you can't out Evan Evan and it's not
because I'm great it's just that you're
trying to do somebody else
I can't out you you and you can't out me
me so when you are yourself when you
figure out what are the things that make
you come alive what makes you tick what
make you great and put that into your
business that's how you end up winning
and so how do you determine whether you
should be the first or be the best
what's the best strategy for you I'm
gonna give you three things to think
about
number one do you like sprints and
marathons do you like getting into
something and out of something do you
like day-trading something or do you
like holding forever sprints and
marathons I look at video games as an
example and League of Legends I love
playing League of Legends
I don't play enough I'm not very good at
it but I'm a fan I like playing for the
late game I like playing the the
champions that are gonna scale into the
light game that are gonna be around
forever that the longer the game goes
the strong gonna get I'm gonna get I
play through defense I push my defense I
build a solid defense and I built out in
all the strategy games that I've ever
played I don't like the fast wins I play
for the forever game and so if you like
the Sprint's then you can get into an
industry really quick and get out really
quick and make some money because nobody
was ever really good at it period right
you win because everybody else sucked
and there's opportunity there's real
arbitrage opportunities to be made and
you don't have to be good you just to be
a little bit better than everybody else
I like the industries where I can be in
forever so I like to join things late
and just be better I joined YouTube
later than a lot of people and I'm
winning because my content is better I
just joined Instagram recently it was
super late to the party and you can
follow along my journey to see me grow
because I'm posting six times a day and
I'm creating content and going live four
times a week and I'm doing the hacks and
doing a strategy and pumping up value
and I'm gonna grow even though I wasn't
first to the party because I'm gonna
provide better quality there was always
room for quality at the top and there
was always room for you to be the best
you period
any industry that you choose to be in
and so if you like sprints and marathons
can help you decide whether you want to
go be the first or be the best number
two is do you like creating trending
content or evergreen content one of the
things you'll notice on this channel is
this very little content around trends
that are happening I don't really pay
attention to a lot of trends I love
making content that will live forever
I love the marathon right I love the
content this video could last forever if
I do a top 10 rules on Jack Ma it can
last forever the points that he's
talking about can last forever the
advice that I like to share from Eleanor
Roosevelt or Henry Ford or whoever it is
is still relevant today some of it I
don't chase the trending content and so
if you love the trends you love the new
you love the flash then you can go for
being first but if you love the
Evergreen you love the timeless you love
the forever wisdom then play the
marathon game play the late game and go
with being the best and number three is
do you like to date or get married a lot
of people love dating they love the they
love the quick interactions they love
the celebration they love cheering on
their wins and some people love getting
married you know I love my marriage much
more than the wedding I didn't really
care what happened at the wedding
because it's one day I think about the
marriage I think about how do we stay
together and be happy forever I didn't
care about dating so much I care about
life time and so they're all three
different examples of how to think do
you want to be first or be the best if
you love Sprint's reveal of marathons if
you love evergreen content or you love
trending content if you love dating you
love marriage hopefully a few examples
you to think through to think do you
want to go and be the first not be very
good but still win because your first or
focus on the long-term and be the best
to be the best forever win win win I'm
geared on one side maybe Jack's on the
other side I'd love to hear your
thoughts now the special bonus clip that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that I want to know what do you think do
you want to be first or do you want to
be the best leave in the comments below
I want to hear your thoughts thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
expresso give me go
you just have to try different things
and even even if 99% of them fail you
only have to be right one time you don't
have to figure it all out in advance you
can be wrong you could pick the wrong
career you can pick the wrong job you
can pick the wrong spouse you can pick
the wrong whatever but you get it right
one time you're set but if you don't try
and if you don't go out there and try
all those different things you'll never
get that one time and so it's not a
question of okay how much different
stuff do I do or how many different
things should you try try them all try
them all till you find the one you like
and then it's like it gets really easy
cuz even when it's up you're on a
mission you're loving what you do you
know and then then it gets easy and so
that's just the approach I've always
tried to instill in people who work for
me and myself so 13 years of Nestle
tiers of PepsiCo 13 years at City now
four to five years of MasterCard that's
quite a few career transitions that
you've had I think many of us expect to
also have a lot of career transitions
yeah as you've gone about your career
and made these big jobs
how have you thought about timing and
reasoning for when you leave one place
and go to the next timing very poor I
just make the jump and I think I'm ready
to make it I in truth in my my
generation who sustained careers for a
long time thirty years in one company
you guys are different and I think
you've got the right approach to it
because if you don't try out new things
if you're not willing to take a risk you
will achieve very little reward out of
the system the way it's constructed
today and so I have a big encouragement
saying you if you want to move jobs or
you want to move roles within a company
or you want to move companies or
industries think about it but go for it
don't don't
don't procrastinate forever and don't
hesitate forever so timing in my case
was more about when I felt that I had
learned what I could and I wanted to do
something different in my mind felt that
I was reaching a point where I was
stagnating you know what I've learned
over the years with me is that trying
new things ends up usually going pretty
well and you know that's where you start
to get more confidence in yourself and
and if anything you just learned
something and you have an experience and
life is about experiences and if
something exciting comes your way just
say yes you know just try something new
and not be afraid and the worst thing
you do is fail and you just don't do it
anymore you just dare you try again
so new experiences are how you grow and
I think that that goes back to the core
of like even just living in a new
country when I was 16 I grew up so fast
because I did that and it's about doing
things that are outside of your comfort
zone and something something you would
not do if you tell yourself a story long
enough you start to believe it don't you
believe it you act like I am Tulsa what
a wail out of handcuffs lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad on
the last week I murdered a rock into the
stone hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I
make medicine sick the fundamental key
to success is it can take between 18 and
250 4 days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access